[Music]
the question is if you get a cloth
dripping wet without gravity and you
wring it out what's gonna happen
this is International Space Station
commander Chris Hadfield performing an
experiment for to tenth grade Canadian
students I love the fact that something
so simple can be turned into such an
interesting experiment just because it's
carried out in space and now let's let's
start ringing it up
it's really wet
[Music]
for me this is totally unexpected I
didn't think that it would stay so close
to the washcloth I thought that the
drops of water would have flown around
into my hands so what type of freaky
space station science is happening here
on earth when you wring out a washcloth
you're applying pressure to it and that
pressure is pushing all the water
molecules outside of the fabric of the
washcloth and when you do that gravity
takes over grabs them and pulls them to
the ground on the International Space
Station that water is effectively
weightless it doesn't fall to the ground
instead it just hovers around the water
clock weird
[Music]
the water sort of has it sticked to my
hand and the reason that water doesn't
just fall off or go other places is a
thing called surface tension basically
water molecules tend to want to stick
together due to the opposing charges and
because there's no other force such as
gravity trying to pull them away all
they're gonna do is just spread out but
continue to stick to each other look it
even wringing out a washcloth this
interesting in space